here we are in the hungry giraffe
exercise for this exercise it's all
based off of onmousemove so when I move
my mouse up and down the draft moves up
and down and when he gets to a certain
point on the screen his mouth opens up
and the leaf goes to his mouth so if I
look at the code that I've been given
the giraffes already been drawn for me
and what I'm working on right now is the
onmousemove function so if I run my code
when the giraffe goes up the leaf goes
to his mouth but I'm not seeing his
mouth appear so let's look at our code
and see what might be wrong here on line
65 there is a variable called giraffe
smile and it has a visibility property
and it's set to false if I change that
to true and run my code again I should
see the mouth appear go to the top the
mouth appears the leaf goes to the mouth
in the solution screen same thing
happens there so I'm going to run the
auto graders check to make sure it's
right and my feedback is you got it so
we were able to complete this exercise
successfully we can go back to the
lesson screen and move forward